en prépa et au concours on dit souvent
que la dissertation est une épreuve de
méthode
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que c'est la méthode pas les
connaissances c'est la méthode qui
permet de réussir une épreuve de
dissertation en prépa et aux concours
d'accord mais c'est quoi la méthode la
méthode c'est étymologiquement le chemin
plus précisément c'est une suite
d'opérations à accomplir pour arriver à
un résultat en évitant des errements si
vous êtes prêt pas si vous préparez un
concours ce n'est pas en apprenant votre
cour que vous allez réussir vos
dissertation c'est en prenant le bon
chemin pourquoi ma méthode est-elle
spéciale parce que je ne vais pas
apprise d'un professeur n'y trouvait
dans un manuel c'est moi même qu'ils
aient élaboré par la pratique
j'ai traité des centaines de sujets fait
des centaines de plans détaillés rédiger
des centaines de dissertation donné des
milliers d'heures de cours à des
étudiants qui préparaient des concours
j'ai fait tout ça depuis une dizaine
d'années et j'ai élaboré ma propre
méthode de dissertation au fur et à
mesure j'ai pu tester beaucoup de choses
j'ai retiré ce qui ne marche pas
j'ai bien sûr conserver ce qui marche et
j'ai ajouté de nouvelles techniques
grâce auquel il est bien plus facile de
faire une dissertation
alors je ne peux pas vous présenter ma
méthode dans le détail ça prendrait
beaucoup trop de temps donc dans cette
vidéo je vais simplement vous expliquer
les sept grandes étapes que je suis à
chaque fois que je fais une dissertation
si vous les entrées dans le détail si
vous voulez des consignes précises des
techniques et des exemples
inscrivez-vous à mon cours gratuits de
méthodologie de la dissertation soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit en cliquant sur celui qui est dans
la description de cette vidéo c'est un
cours par email vous pourrez le
découvrir
après la vidéo ou dans les prochains
jours là maintenant tout de suite
regardé attentivement cette vidéo
jusqu'au bout et vous serez bien plus à
l'aise dès votre prochain l'épreuve de
dissertation
est ce que vous savez quoi faire lorsque
vous découvrez le sujet beaucoup
d'élèves se met à réfléchir sans savoir
à quoi ils doivent réfléchir mais il y a
pire des élèves note frénétiquement sur
leurs feuilles de brouillon tout ce dont
ils se souviennent de leurs cours vous
pensez vraiment que c'est ça
traiter le sujet bien sûr que non quelle
est la bonne solution
vous devez d'abord réfléchir
stratégiquement au sujet c'est pour ça
que j'appelle cette toute première étape
la réflexion stratégique
mais en quoi ça consiste précisément la
stratégie ça consiste à anticiper les
éventualités
vous devez donc vous poser les bonnes
questions sur le sujet afin d'en
identifier les enjeux c'est à dire ce
qui est important pour le traiter et
deux de prévoir des pistes de solution
pour faire face aux difficultés par
tirer parti des opportunités
moi je donne à mes élèves une liste de
questions simples comme ça ils n'ont pas
besoin de se prendre la tête pour
traiter le sujet de leur dissertation
dès qu'ils découvrent l'énoncé ils ont
simplement à répondre à quelques
questions
cette toute première étape est
probablement la plus importante parce
qu'elle vous permettra d'éviter les
pièges de desserte et plus efficacement
et de gagner du temps allez deuxième
étape
j'imagine que ça vous est déjà arrivé
le hors sujet mais comment savoir si
vous êtes dans le sujet comment savoir
si vos idées sont pertinentes
comment savoir si vous n'oubliez pas des
idées importantes
le problème c'est souvent que vous vous
perdez dans le monde des idées votre
sujet de dissertation porte une question
intellectuelle donc vous croyez qu'il
est sans rapport avec la réalité
concrète mais c'est faux les idées et la
matière sont en constante interaction
votre sujet a des racines et des
implications dans le monde réel
c'est pour cette raison que vous avez
intérêt à chercher des exemples pour
délimiter le champ du sujet un exemple
c'est bien plus facile de savoir s'il
est pertinent et comme ça vous saurez si
les idées liées à chaque exemple le sont
elles aussi donc la deuxième étape de ma
méthode de dissertation ça consiste à
chercher des exemples concrets et précis
concrets ça veut dire que la chose peut
être perçue par les sens et précis ça
veut dire que la chose ne peut pas être
re divisé en éléments plus petits allez
on passe à la troisième étape de ma
méthode de dissertation
je viens de vous expliquer que vous
devez trouver des exemples concrets et
précis et qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
immédiatement après vous avoir dit ça
j'ai défini les objectifs concrets et
précis afin que vous puissiez avoir la
meilleure compréhension possible de
mâcon si si vous voulez manipuler
efficacement les idées ça doit devenir
un réflexe définissez les maux dont vous
vous servez comme la dissertation et
surtout un exercice de réflexion la
définition des termes du sujet est une
étape importante de ma méthode c'est la
troisième c'est même une étape cruciale
parce qu'elle conditionne les prochaines
étapes par exemple c'est peut-être une
nuance de définition qui vous aidera à
élaborer votre plan ou bien elle vous
permettra peut-être de trouver le
problème intellectuel précis à résoudre
dans la dissertation
bref cette étape de la définition des
termes peut être un investissement très
rentable donc définissez les termes du
sujet avec soin les étapes suivantes
tout est ce que vous la sortez la
problématique d'un chapeau comme un
magicien ou bien est-ce qu'il faut être
inspirés comme un artiste
est-ce qu'il faut avoir un coup de
chance vous pensez peut-être que ça se
passe comme ça et plein d'élèves pense
comme vous c'est pour ça que j'ai
élaboré une technique logique est simple
pour problématiser un sujet de
dissertation
il suffit de faire trois choses d'abord
vous identifier clairement le point de
départ de votre réflexion
ensuite vous en déduisez le problème
intellectuel à résoudre dans la
dissertation et enfin vous formulez ce
problème intellectuel sous la forme
d'une question là je vous ai simplement
présenter les opérations de ma technique
parce que j'ai déjà publié une vidéo qui
vous explique tout dans le détail elle
s'intitule problématique de dissertation
comment la trouvez logiquement vous la
trouverez facilement sur cette chaîne
youtube
je ne vous en dis donc pas plus sur la
problématisation on passe à la 5e étape
après qu'on vous a posé une question
c'est le moment de répondre une fois que
vous avez trouvé question c'est à dire
la problématique c'est donc le bon
moment de réfléchir à la réponse c'est
pour ça que vous devez élaborer le plan
de votre dissertation maintenant et non
pas avant et encore moins au début de
l'épreuve
la cinquième étape de ma méthode de
dissertation ça consiste donc à élaborer
le plan mais par plan j'entends
seulement les grandes parties du
développement de votre dissertation
selon votre épreuve et votre sujet il y
en aura deux trois ou quatre
concentrez-vous exclusivement sur les
grande partie parce que si vous cherchez
en même temps les grandes parties les
sous parties et les références ça sera
plus compliqué et vous risquerez de
mélanger les différents niveaux d'idées
les idées plus générale avec les idées
plus précises à les étapes suivantes
je ne vais pas vous jeter la pierre moi
aussi quand je découvre un sujet je
pense instantanément à des références je
me dis par exemple
ah tiens je pourrais parler d'aristote
nom patois aristote 1 moi aussi je
réfléchis automatiquement comme ça
lorsque je découvre le sujet mais ce
n'est pas pour autant que je me dis il
faut à tout prix que je parle d'aristote
ce n'est pas pour autant que je me mets
à gries fouiller toutes les références
qui me viennent à l'esprit sur mes
feuilles de brouillon
non vous devez concentrer votre esprit
sur les références au bon moment une
fois que vous connaissez les grandes
parties du développement de votre
dissertation
c'est le bon moment cette étape c'est ce
que j'appelle l'argumentation il s'agit
de trouver les arguments c'est à dire
les idées précises qui prouve la
pertinence des idées générales que sont
les grandes parties du développement de
votre dissertation et c'est là que pour
convaincre le correcteur de la
crédibilité de vos arguments c'est là
que vous cherchez des références ou plus
généralement des éléments de
connaissance d'accord allez 7e et
dernière étape de ma méthode
bon vous avez compris
qu'est ce qu'il reste eh bien il reste
la rédaction vous avez vos définitions
en des termes du sujet votre
problématique vos grande partie vos
arguments et vos références vous avez
tous les ingrédients donc il est temps
de cuisiner la 7e et dernière étape de
ma méthode
ça consiste donc à rédiger toujours
metodi je mens l'introduction le
développement et la conclusion de votre
dissertation
si vous voulez des conseillers précise
pour rédiger les trois partis de la
dissertation
j'ai publié les vidéos concernant
chacune d'entre elles vous les trouverez
facilement sur cette chaîne youtube
je vous rappelle les sept étapes de ma
méthode de dissertation pour la préparer
les concours réfléchir stratégiquement
au sujet chercher des exemples défini
les termes du sujet problématiser le
sujet trouver les grandes parties du
développement de la dissertation trouver
les arguments et les références et enfin
combiner tous ces ingrédients pour
rédiger la dissertation finale si vous
vous inspirer de ma méthode voire même
si vous suivez exactement les mêmes
étapes vous allez vous rendre la tâche
bien plus facile maintenant si vous
voulez des consignes précises des
techniques et des exemples
inscrivez-vous à mon cours gratuits de
méthodologie de la dissertation soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant ou à droite de la vidéo soit
en cliquant sur celui qui est dans la
description de cette vidéo
voilà voilà j'espère vraiment que cette
vidéo vous aidera à être plus méthodique
en dissertation je suis romain je suis
toujours avec mon fidèle aristote et
vous étiez sur mille idées de culture
générale rappelez vous vous n'avez pas
besoin de vous prendre la tête pour
réussir vos épreuves de dissertation
[Musique]